andrew simmons takes a look back at his
life
he was by her side throughout the
longest reign of a monarch in british
history
for prince philip duke of edinburgh it
wasn't only a marriage but a life of
service to his wife queen elizabeth ii
born into greek and danish royalty
philip had a lonely childhood
he was taken under the wing of the
british aristocracy
when he married the then princess
elizabeth in 1947 he was a promising
young naval officer
it was a fairytale wedding for a country
emerging from war and hardship
it all changed for the young couple when
elizabeth's father king george vi
died at only 56 years of age she became
queen
and philip in the words of his private
secretary looked as if the world had
fallen down on him
his naval career ended along with his
independence
prince philip was sort of forced into
making huge sacrifices
he was very much a man's man not someone
who was
going to naturally fall into the
position of playing second fiddle and
walking two paces behind his wife and
calling her ma'am in public and so on
and so began life in the queen's shadow
hundreds of engagements a year
he did however manage to find time for
his own charities
helping young people and conserving
wildlife very energetic
um a problem solve a sort of scientific
cast of mind
so those were sort of you know on the
positive side the
the attributes that people admired
sometimes though
you know his his detractors would would
say that
you know some of his forthrightness
could come across as
rudeness philip did have a reputation
for embarrassing and politically
incorrect remarks
whether he was being rude about the
chinese or indians
or swearing at photographers often a
sideshow to formal occasions
yet even though an air of racism hung
over him
a staunchly royalist uk media generally
forgave him
he was certainly given a much easier
ride than politicians politicians who
tend to make
a racist or an offensive remark in this
day and age tend to have to apologize a
couple of days later because there's so
much pressure on them
but i've never known prince philip to
apologize for a remark and
i remember once uh he wandered over
after he'd uh said to an aboriginal
leader do you still throw spears at each
other
and i saw him do this in australia in
2002 and
the next day he came over it made front
pages all over the world
and he just wandered over and said the
trouble with you is you've got no sense
of humor the complete absence of humor
so he wasn't going to apologize his
retirement from public duties came
in 2017 with a send-off from the royal
[Music]
marines
whatever the faults his 60 years of
public service was admired by many
people
while their marriage was said to have
had its ups and downs in the couple's
younger years
prince philip remained dedicated and
supportive
to the queen she'll receive immense
sympathy from a british public known to
view her
with respect and affection